sir the question says it's a manatee son
okay so there's a father
and then there's a son
okay now you have to help me out here I
think it says currently the father right
now is three times in this son three
times over and it says if we go forward
12 years
the father will then be twice the age of
the son yeah so this is like now we add
12 years 12 years elapsed that's right
it feels like if I will be done with the
Ames
okay so like I said this is really bad
interpretation and sort of how can you
translate from this okay
now the first thing you want to do is
you gotta set up okay I've got numbers
I've got unknowns so clearly this is
about translating this into algebra
right so I'm going to introduce some
perennials to stand for some stuff what
would you like to suggest yeah okay so I
could say so age 500 to two things
number one I'm going to encourage you to
choose a pruning rule that is meaningful
now you could choose anything you like
I'm gonna call it s for son because this
question is confusing it up on its own
without me forgetting am I talking about
the father or the son right now okay so
I'm gonna say the Sun is a call that yes
but on top of that we need to be a
little more specific because the
question of the son's age begs the
question well the son's age when right
and there are two distinct time periods
here so there's now and then there's
later okay now you really can choose it
whichever way you like after this once
we're done I'll have a go at solving it
the other way and see what happened okay
which would you like the son's age s to
be you want to be now or later
sure why not
so the Sun is currently su solved right
now okay so far so good
now you can sneak under everyone I need
to introduce more printer rules don't I
do i yeah okay so if I introducing you
pretty good
like say oh I don't know the father's
age okay now just like before so that I
am minimally computing I'm going to
specified and when I drew DiFonzo just
since I'm already chosen now I might as
well stay right now so we'll just assign
that the letter okay so now my task is
to take what I got up here depends like
that take what I've got here which I can
also translate and then see how these
two are gonna dance together so right
now the father's image is going to be
three times like literally three times
the sons and so that is true right now
this second that's one equation I've
just translated it straight out of there
now twelve years have to pass so if the
farthest edge is right now F then in
twelve years it's not going to be F any
more it will be sure
it's erased okay but what the father's
age is increasing if there are time
machines are relativistic travel
involved this son is also aging at the
same pace the great so when I'm about to
write this right hand side which also
connects the father's age to the son's
age
it's the son's age in the future just
like it's the father's age in the future
the father in the future will be how
much older than the Sun double that age
and that age has also increased by 12 if
you came with that okay I have two
questions I will try to do something
here that's - yes so you can see I've
got an equation here I've got an
equation here does it check out do you
agree with how I got those numbers and
how I arranged it so if you agree with
that well let's just see where it takes
us go crazy in one foot crazy - actually
I should have tightened up in a feather
and equals to 12 let's hold that
question usually
what would you like me to do okay so
both of them have F as the subject so I
might as alt meant one and two equal to
each other so I'm going to so about here
2x plus 12 equals 3 s so s therefore
must be equal to oh right what is that
that's the son's age and right now so
therefore the father's age right now and
of course you can just double-check that
does it work when 12 years passed how
all those are sunbae he'll be 24 and
what about the father for you which is
indeed twice